I have a story for you today. That's a really
unfortunate story and it's been a difficult
thing for us, but I hope that if nothing else,
it'll be an interesting kind of peek behind
the curtain of some of the things going on
with podcasting and your data and you being
tracked when you listen to shows like the
David Pakman show. So let's just get right
into it. The David Pakman show exists on a
bunch of different platforms. Many of you
know this. We do a video show. We do an audio
show every day. The video show gets uploaded
to YouTube and to Facebook. We send it to
our television affiliates. Free speech TV
runs it on DirecTV and dish network. That's
the video show. We also do an audio version
and that's distributed to a bunch of different
radio stations. We also have it on Spotify.
It's an audio podcast. We've had the audio
podcast for many, many years. We work with
a hosting company called Libsyn for our podcast
files. So when you listen to our podcast,
whether you're on iTunes or on Spotify or@davidpakman.com
or whatever, the files themselves exist, or
they live on servers that this company called
Libsyn runs. That's where the files are Lipson's
a great company and they're one of the reasons
that the podcast has been able to scale the
way that it has. One of the reasons we worked
with Libsyn from the beginning was that they
only charge you for storage space. They don't
start a charge you for bandwidth, meaning
that we pay the same amount no matter how
many downloads we get. So when you consider
that the podcast today is more than 10 times
bigger than it was when we started with Libsyn,
uh, this is huge for us because we pay the
same amount now for our hosting as we did
10 years ago when the show was only a 10%
the size that it is today.
Now, as many of you also might know, one of
the ways that the David Pakman show makes
money is by running advertisements. So sometimes
at the end of a YouTube video there will be
an ad. Sometimes if you're listening to the
podcast, there will be an ad between segments.
These ads come from a bunch of different places,
but one of the biggest relationships that
we have for getting these ads on the show
is with an ad agency called Midroll. We started
working with Midroll years ago and over time,
Midroll has been acquired a couple of times
by other companies. They're now part of the
same company that owns the podcasting app,
Stitcher, and we've done a lot of advertising
deals with them. Thankfully they've brought
us a significant amount of revenue. A lot
of those ads that you see at the end of a
YouTube video or that you hear on the podcast
were brought to us by mid-roll.
This is a great thing. It's been a great relationship,
but a couple of months ago we were contacted
by mid-roll and they said, listen, we want
to transition you over to hosting your podcast
with a company called Omni O, M N, Y. Now,
before I even looked into this company, I
thought it's a little weird for an ad agency
to come in and say, Hey, you need to change
your podcast host if you want to continue
working with us in the way that you've been
working with us. And I said to them, well,
hold on a second. I'm very happy with our
current podcast hosts, Libsyn. I'm not inclined
to change, but is this an ultimatum? Like
are you saying either I hire a different podcast
host or you will cut off the money that we
get from advertisements that you send us?
Are you telling me that unless I change hosts,
I will lose all ad revenue that we get from
you?
And we went back and forth for a little bit
and to make a long story short, yeah, that's
the case. Unless we switch to this other company,
Omni to host our podcast, we will lose all
of the revenue that we get by running the
ads that Midroll has been bringing us. Now
before I even go any further because we're
not even talking about your data yet, we're
going to get to that in a second. Before I
go any further, this is already a very strong
arm action to come in and say, unless you
become the customer of this particular company,
we're going to take away a whole bunch of
money, particularly when it's money that's
now part of our budget. We use the ad revenue
to pay salaries and to buy equipment and for
connectivity and all of the, you know, rent
studio, rent, all of that stuff.
We abide by all of the guidelines that Midroll
puts in place. We do all the right stuff,
and now they're coming in and saying, Hey,
listen, you've got to go and become a customer
of someone else if you want to keep getting
any revenue for it from us. But that's only
part one. It actually gets much worse. So
I started looking into the sales pitch that
we were being given about Omni and I saw that
one of the big selling points was that Omni
would create or provide much better analytics
about you, about our audience, which could
then be used to sell ads and to target ads
in a better way. Now, this raised a red flag
for me and as I researched it more, I learned
that the way Omni does this is via what's
called a tracking pixel. Now, without getting
into the technology, tracking pixels are used
in a lot of different advertising contexts.
It allows for your behavior to be tracked
across the internet, often across devices
and to be used as part of the sales pitch
to potential sponsors by mid-roll. Now I asked,
is that opt in for our audience? Is our audience
consenting to be tracked in that way? And
I was told, no, it is not you. If I made the
switch, would not have any say in being tracked
in this way by Omni. Now, this is not illegal
in the United States. It's questionable, but
interestingly, as far as I can tell, this
is illegal in Europe on the basis of the new
GDPR guidelines that now exist. So listen,
financially, I'm making the wrong decision
here, but I am not going to bow to this bullying
pressure nor am I going to subject you to
being tracked, which while not illegal, I
find immoral to just switch.
There's no opt in and you're just being tracked
in a different way by my podcast. I get it.
We know that this is happening on Facebook,
we know it's happening elsewhere, but I don't
want that happening with my podcast. So the
good news for you in a sense is that starting
in January you may be hearing fewer ads on
the podcast. Uh, you will likely be seeing
fewer ads at the end of YouTube videos because
we are going to be ending our relationship
with mid-roll or maybe better said they are
ending it with us because we're refusing to
go ahead and hire the company that they want
us to hire and to subject you to this tracking.
But the good news is that we are going to
be sticking with Libsyn for our podcast hosting.
We absolutely love them. I'm confident that
over the long run, this is the right decision.
Even if in the short run it is financially
problematic. If in the immediate you want
to help just grab a membership@joinpacman.com
as always, direct support makes us sort of
immune to these types of strong arm tactics
and uh, that's always the best thing to do.
By the way, lots of the shows you likely listen
if this is the only political show you listen
to. Okay? If you'll listen to other lefty
political shows almost for sure, there are
other shows that are dealing with this exact
same pressure from Midroll just as a heads
up and we'll see if any of them discuss it.
Every show will make the decision that's best
for them. And I think that even though it
will be difficult for us, this is the right
decision. Let me know what you think.